[Musique]
bienvenue au jardin naturel à filoche
j'exploite une parcelle de 8000 mètres
carrés alors j'exploite pas encore eu
les huit mètres carrés j'en suis à peu
près à 2500 mètres carrés avec les
fruitiers et le maraîchage
j'ai fait deux ans de fac de bio pour
m'orienter derrière sur un bts
productions végétales après j'ai voulu
faire de l'agriculture tropicale
je suis venu à la réunion pour faire une
licence en agriculture
donc j'ai été refusé la première année
donc j'ai fait en attendant une licence
de cuisine d'hôtellerie-restauration que
j'ai obtenus et après j'ai été accepté
dans ma licence d'agriculture et
développement durable l'entreprise au
jardin naturel parce que du coup je ne
produis mes légumes sans produits
chimiques
je refuse de mettre quoi que ce soit et
des fois il ya des pertes ou aussi bas
l'environnement s'équilibre toute façon
tout seul donc les auxiliaires arrive
pour tuer les ravageurs et c'est la
nature qui fait ça on rêve de petite
fille était de faire une ferme est de
pouvoir accueillir des gens pour qu on
cultive ensemble et qu'on mange ensemble
c'est ce que j'aimerais créer un peu
assis loos un modèle d'échangé de
partage sur ce terrain agricole pour
qu'on puisse cultiver manger aussi
après oui faut que je m'en sorte
économiquement du coup j'ai fait de la
confiture dégeler aussi de plantes
aromatiques et les salades et les
rouleaux de printemps qui m'apporte un
revenu
plus confortable que les légumes brut et
qui me permet aussi d'entretenir ma
passion qui est la cuisine
il me manque quand même des moyens
humains et matériels faut que
j'investisse aussi dans un broyeur pour
m'apporter la matière organique peu
cheap à petits pas tout produit à cilaos
je fais aussi mais semences je plante
tous les plans je n'achète rien
pépinière j'essaye de faire tout le plus
respectueux de la nature possible du
pays
aussi les légumes lontan il ya des
poèmes a qui poussent des poids sabroso
6 mais j'aimerais bien arriver à une
grosse diversité de produits longtemps
possible à planter sur cilaos
je suis trop bien pour rien au monde tu
partirais de cilaos
mangez bien mangez sain manger pays
c'est bon pour la santé
[Musique]
m
bienvenue à saint-pierre précisément sur
terre sainte je me disparu
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je ne vis pas praticienne
esthéticienne mais je suis aussi
aromathérapeute et phytothérapeute j'ai
travaillé dans plusieurs instituts
plusieurs soupirs maintenant je monte
des concepts ce parc à la réunion et
ensuite j'ai vu l'envolée de me
proposait légers augmenter son petit
jardin du pays qui a ici est vraiment
essayé de mettre en avant la créativité
dans savoir faire j'ai fait les départs
initiative réunion et france active
également
j'avais besoin d'un perdant il était là
pour m'aider et grâce à lui j'ai pu
avoir mon prêt et voir construire et
bâtir ce petit ces petits bijoux
[Musique]
le plus important pour moi cette
favoriser l'agriculture réunionnaise et
le savoir-faire règle
à travers mes soins et lui à travers
également tout ce qu'on peut partager
ici avec les artisans les créateurs et
les agriculteurs donc je propose des
soins toujours personnaliser et globale
fonction du besoin de chaque individu de
chaque peau de chaque type de peau vous
avez tout magasin de produits
cosmétiques hausse à face justement
d'une production raisonnable avec un
circuit court qui se crée entre les
agriculteurs moi même et ensuite vous
mes clients également je tiens ici par
exemple c'est une petite nouveauté j'ai
voulu travailler avec le sel marin de
saint leu en proposant des sels de bain
aromatisés dont creuse et romarin
ravintsara on a également donc les
gommages gommage café bourbon pointu par
exemple pour venir y vais un peu toutes
les cellules est venu à travailler sur
la rétention d'eau et c'est donc avec
n'importe quelle plante on veut vraiment
travailler sur des actifs bien précis et
essayer de trouver des alliances entre
chaque actif pour trouver la meilleure
recette notre visage pour notre
et vraiment un apport au naturel en
essayant de viser le plus possible les
fruits légumes et plantes longtemps de
la règne en passant par le biais
d'apiculteurs agriculteurs tisanes et
herboriste je suis aujourd'hui la seule
à pouvoir rpt transformer ses produits
ses actifs réunionnais en intégrant dans
mes cosmétiques par le biais de mon
laboratoire qui justement développe
davantage c'est une gamme de produits
cosmétiques 100 % naturel et 100% pays
et ne bouge pas nous reste à la réunion
et nous mettent en avant leur savoir
faire
[Musique]
le produit pays a été mise en l'air à
l'issue de la finale du challenge des
créateurs d'entreprises dans l'hémicycle
du département
sarah penche baiia de l'entreprise
baudis pas remporté cette catégorie
[Musique]
ap
et elle aussi